estamos de regreso en france 24 para
conocer las principales noticias en
materia económica de américa latina y
del resto del mundo y para hacerlo nos
acompaña por supuesto nuestro compañero
jorge hurtado jorge muy buenas noches
vamos a continuar con un tema que
estuvimos tratando en toda la
programación hoy de france 24 que tiene
que ver con el techo de deuda en eeuu
así es hace unos minutos la solución
temporal fue aprobada por el senado los
líderes del senado de eeuu alcanzaron un
acuerdo para evitar el impago de la
deuda pública a mediados de octubre
luego de semanas de lucha partidaria del
aumento sería de 480 mil millones de
dólares con un nuevo límite hasta el 3
de diciembre y que resucitará la
discusión durante las próximas ocho
semanas santiago el techo de la deuda es
la cantidad de dinero que el gobierno
podría prestar para pagar sus cuentas la
necesidad de elevarlo viene de que este
año los gastos del gobierno son de 58
billones de dólares pero tendría 3,5
billones de ingresos lo que dejaría un
27 213 billones de dólares el techo ha
sido modificado al menos 78 veces desde
los años 60
gracias como bien explicado el tema del
techo que suelen surgir dudas al
respecto vamos ahora a centroamérica se
están destinando fondos para esta región
que lo necesita muchísimo así es bueno
el fondo verde del clima otorgó al
denominado corredor seco centroamericano
174,3 millones de dólares que se van a
destinar a combatir la crisis climática
santiago el corredor seco
centroamericano abarca las costas
pacíficas de guatemala el salvador
honduras nicaragua costa rica y panamá y
actualmente es una de las zonas más
vulnerables del mundo a la crisis
climática el banco centroamericano de
integración económica informó que estos
recursos beneficiarán a 2,4 millones de
personas a través del acceso a
asistencia técnica y crédito
este dinero es parte del programa
centroamericano de reconstrucción
resiliente de más de 2 mil 500 millones
de dólares que dicho fondo fue aprobado
por el banco regional en noviembre del
2020 cuando pasaron por ahí los
huracanes y traeré yo está bueno
seguiremos de cerca cómo va la
asignación de estos fondos jorge vamos a
hablar ahora de un tema muy importante
que tiene que ver con la post pandemia y
nuevos modos de trabajo no a lo que se
está adaptando la gente y hablamos
específicamente de los coworking space
que tras 18 meses de pandemia se mudan
al aire libre en sao paulo la ciudad más
grande de brasil estas empresas
trasladaron sus oficinas hacia las
azotea y terraza actualmente hay
alrededor de 200 espacios de coworking
ahí la mayoría en exteriores en todo
brasil los espacios de coworking se
multiplicaron por 6 entre 2015 y 2019 y
llegan ahora a mil 500 lugares veamos
que cuentan los dueños de estos
coworking
propio de mi a 95 empresas antes de la
pandemia el 95% de las empresas que
usaban el work eran empresas de
tecnología con la pandemia otros
mercados buscaron una solución más
eficiente e inteligente y menos costosa
que las oficinas empezaron a buscar
otros espacios hoy el 40 por ciento de
las empresas que utilizan word están en
el mercado tradicional abogados
consultoras auditorías
consultorías auditorías cabe mencionar
que esta semana santiago uno de los co
working más grandes del mundo we work
informó que sus ingresos de septiembre
alcanzaron los 228 millones de dólares
las ventas mensuales más altas de este
año para esa empresa que pronto va a
entrar a cotizar en la bolsa de nueva
york sin duda de los más beneficiados
por la pandemia jorge vamos ahora españa
donde van a dar un estímulo económico a
los jóvenes de 18 años de qué se trata
esto bueno les van a dar 462 dólares
para gastar en actividades culturales
aunque con una condición los
beneficiarios no pueden usarlo para
comprar entradas para corridas de toros
el fondo fue incluido en el presupuesto
nacional del 2022 presentados por el
gobierno este jueves y el objetivo es
ayudar a las empresas españolas
relacionadas con la cultura a
recuperarse de las pérdidas de sus
ingresos durante la pandemia los jóvenes
elegibles podrán gastar sus 462 dólares
en artículos como entradas para el cine
el teatro libros y conciertos medio
millón de personas serán elegibles para
el bono que le costará al estado
alrededor de 220 millones de dólares
francia italia ya tomaron unas medidas
similares continuamos ahora con los
indicadores de la jornada que nos dicen
'bueno wall street cerró en verde con
ganancias luego de el acuerdo para
ampliar el techo de endeudamiento a
corto plazo en europa la bolsa española
logró la tercer mayor alza anual por
eléctricas y 'wall street' y en américa
latina las bolsas mostraron cierta
estabilidad por el techo de la deuda
cerramos con la cifra del día como
siempre 6,3 por ciento es la nueva
previsión de crecimiento económico para
américa latina según el banco mundial
muchísimas gracias porque ataques de
información económica en france24 sigan
informando se en el resto de nuestra
programación gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]